how bad was it in your humble opinion I
think it was pretty bad I mean all you
really have to do as a politician is no
your brief particularly if you're the
leader know your policies be able to
recite your manifesto and be able to
kind of be probed a bit on that and I
think to fail even in that department
was pretty bad and it was certainly
horrendous listening all that coughing
I'm kind of their foe sympathy or I've
got a bad cold and it was pretty grim
and Toby she herself described it is
excruciating how did you find it to
listen to it was difficult to listen to
I mean I think like many people I felt
quite sorry for her listening to it and
you know I felt that you know dead but
for the grace of God go I and that kind
of thing has happened to me I've had a
brain freeze on the radio before I was
once doing an interview for radio for in
banga in Wales and said how ridiculous i
thought it was that all road signs in
wales were in Welsh and English given
what a tiny percentage of the world's
population actually speak Welsh and
afterwards some the studio manager told
me that one of their listeners have been
driving past at the very moment that I
said this and had stopped and had coming
to the studio to have it out with me
yeah but you actually said what you
wanted to say that I mean nice I tweeted
that once created it I mean actually the
you know the brain just going completely
and not really knowing where you're
talking about well I think on a more
positive note that everyone gives
politicians a really hard time but I
think the fact that this is was this was
so remarkable that she had her brain
freeze and she couldn't remember her fax
does actually shows that most of the
time our politicians are pretty
competent they they're quite fluent on
the telly they may be incredibly
annoying like Michael Howard when he
wouldn't ask answer the question or I
love I remember that amazing interview
you did with Alastair Campbell you
practically had fisticuffs on there
because he was talking so Alice camel
was unavailable to discuss it yeah
people complain about the
professionalisation politics but you
know if we had more amateurs in politics
this kind of thing which is what might
the public be quite forgiving it for
that reason they see someone whose tomb
and they think I've had moments like
that myself and they don't necessarily
want someone who's completely media
trained one slick well they all quite
forgiving on Twitter actually
interestingly when I said I was coming
on to talk about this quite a few
people said oh you know be gentle on her
poor matthew bennett you know she's
doing her best i don't actually think
that cuts it i think if you're a
professional like if Toby and I wrote a
terrible column we'd be in trouble for a
job but she's agreed really I mean day
green tea recently do people go to your
greens for the final words of mortgage
tax relief i suspect they know i think i
don't know what the green stand for
think I human level I think people will
be quite forgiving it may actually end
up making them like her more but
politically I think it's quite damaging
because the Greens after all are
proposing a massive increase in public
expenditure they're not very keen on
economic growth so they've got to figure
out where the money for things like
building half a million new homes which
is a flagship policy are going to come
from and if that is one of your flagship
policies on the day you launch your
manifesto if you're the leader of the
party you should be expected to know
where the money's coming from so if the
public might feel sympathy as you say on
a human level how do you think that
other prospective green candidates
around the country might feel to have
heard that interview well if I was a
green canter i felt absolutely gutted
there they are they've got a really good
head head wind in the polls and I know a
lot of people who voted lib dem last
time who are now saying they're going to
vote green I think they were becoming a
kind of left version of UK as UK part of
the Tories there were lots of quite
sensible people who were thinking about
voting for them and I think that they
must now be thinking maybe not such a
great idea really does sound bananas and
if you're a credible green candidate
with stuff to say you really believe in
this stuff you'll be absolutely furious
that she shot the whole pass him okay
you both Jonas you've both been
interviewers what's your worst moment as
an interview oh I was on LBC and I got
just got this new title editorial
director and I was in their last me what
it meant and I'd had a total brain
freeze got my dad directing editorial oh
you know where that was really bad i
feel like an idiot I once interviewed
the Broadway style Nathan Lane who just
appeared in a movie called The Birdcage
and I thought charge of a bit of a scoop
here I first asked him whether he was
Jewish and he got very put out about
that and said yes yes what of it next
question and I said okay Eve often
played gay characters you even did the
voiceover for Tim ohn in the Lion King
generally considered Disney's first ever
animated gay character are you a
homosexual
and he just got up and walked out I got
back to me I got back to the office and
great and part at the end of the Vanity
Fair then my boss said Toby what are you
thinking you can't ask Broadway musical
stars whether they're Jewish or a gay it
future just assume that all Jewish and
all gay okay